my youngest has a real power move ryan
gosling gives a rare interview about his
daughter and her hilarious power move on
the tonight show starring jimmy fallon
ryan shares how his six-year-old amada
calls it how she sees it the 41 year old
actor recalls a family trip to france
and while roaming around the louvre his
little girl gave this unenthusiastic
review we're standing in front of the
mona lisa and she turns around and she
goes this museum
[Applause]
gotta love a young lady who knows what
she likes and doesn't like and the real
power move is sometimes she'll turn
around and she'll just go
[Applause]
down walk away walk away oh that's
fantastic move it's like roman emperor
levels
of course ryan's fans know he's a super
private guy who rarely talks about his
family life with eva mendes so learning
about amada's power move was a real
treat she turns around and she goes this
museum
roman emperor levels
but we're giving ryan a thumbs up
specifically for his latest gig playing
ken in the upcoming barbie film
let's
i can't wait for people to see the film
of course fans are itching to see ryan
in the role after this shirtless sneak
peek broke the internet
yeah well i have that energy can you
explain the kenergy for me you know a
can in your life and then you know that
that can has canergy well it's the
cannascan's per it's the kennesaw yeah
expect the kennesaw's next year when the
greta gerwig directed film hits theaters
in the meantime seems we have ryan's
daughters to thank for him actually
saying yes to the gig best script i've
ever read i walk out in the backyard and
you know where i found ken jimmy
face down in the mud next to a squished
lemon and this is this is a pho you took
a photo of it
and this is a sign
this is a sign
that you got to do this
thing utter disrespect i texted it to
greta and i said i shall be your kin
for his story must be told and thanks to
ava we know ryan kept a thing or two
from the set i saw the photo and the 14
year old in me was like oh yeah but i
you know it's a it's a funny it's a
funny photo and he's trying to be funny
but um so it worked on all levels but i
when i saw it he sent it to me from work
and i said
can i please have that underwear
please
where are they in your home
that
i would have to ask her i don't you know
i don't i don't speak for eva mendes
ryan speaking on behalf of fans
everywhere thank you for bringing the
kinergy on screen and in real life
[Music]